après le japon et la californie toyota
choisi le québec comme banc d'essai pour
tester la muraille ce véhicule à
hydrogène lancée en 2014 se recharge en
cinq minutes et possède une autonomie de
500 km avec un hydrogène des mais aucun
émissions polluantes la seule émission
qu'un véhicule à sept laux h2o
l'hydrogène est mélangée à de l'oxygène
dans la pile du véhicule ce qui produit
de l'électricité pour le propulser le
seul rejet de la vapeur d'eau en vertu
d'un partenariat
toyota va fournir 50 mirail qui
s'ajouteront à la flotte de véhicules du
gouvernement pour québec
la voiture à hydrogène est un autre
moyen d'atteindre ses objectifs
environnementaux
ici dans le cas de la transition
énergétique on veut réduire les gaz à
effet de serre et l'utilisation
l'hydroélectricité pour la production
d'hydrogène est certaine même filière
que nous allons examiner donc hydro
québec pourrait être mise à profit
à l'heure actuelle il n'existe que deux
stations de ravitaillement dans toute la
province
une à brossard dans les installations de
toyota et une autre à l'institut de
recherche sur l'hydrogène de trois
rivières d'ici l'automne prochain
québec financera la construction de deux
nouvelles stations une à québec et une à
montréal qui serait non seulement des
stations de distribution d'hydrogène
mais aussi des stations de production
bref le développement de cette filière
en est à ses balbutiements
on est encore dans les premiers pas y'a
pas de réseaux qui existent l'hydrogène
pour le moment provient massivement du
gaz naturel coûte assez cher à produire
donc on doit mettre un région en marche
toyota compte vendre son véhicule à
hydrogène au grand public canadien à
compter de l'an prochain mais le prix
pourrait en décourager plusieurs à
l'heure actuelle la mirail se vend plus
de 50000 dollars aux états unis et pour
le moment faire le plein d'essence coûte
moins cher qu'un plein d'hydrogène
mais tout ça pourrait changer au fil des
ans ici olivier bachand radio canada
montréal